[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Lauren is
in Chicago hey Lauren welcome to the
Ramsey
Show hi thank you for all the work you
guys do for um American people I um have
been listening for a couple months um to
a lot of the different shows and my
husband and I I'm learning a a little
and we are okay we've made um you know
some good decisions and some bad
decisions based on the ramc way but
right now we're looking at wanting to
pay our house off we don't have any
other debt and how do people do that
like is it okay to just set aside the
money and then pay it off in one lth
some or what is what's the ramsy wayers
a recommendation or a book no it don't
take a book it's just early and often
every month send as much towards the
house payment as you can
send
okay and what happens is it lowers your
balance so the next month more of your
regular payment will go towards
principal than it than it would have if
you hadn't let's say you sent $10,000
okay well you no longer have to pay
interest on that $10,000 so the in the
monthly interest on that
$110,000 less will be low I mean on the
balance will be lower than uh than it
was by $10,000 you follow
me I do I I understand that um I guess
like my husband and I and I agree with
it completely that's what I've learned
and understand however my husband's more
comfortable with having a um lump suum
available just in case um anything
happens with the house any emergency
yeah before you start paying your house
do you have an emergency fund of three
to six months of
expenses um we have an emergency we have
about
160,000 um saved and then we have invest
okay your husband's theory is ludicrous
what do you what is he expecting what
kind what kind of what do you think's
gonna happen
Armageddon your cash won't be good yes
there will not be ATMs during
Armageddon this is so funny thank you
for the laugh
yeah no no what what do you owe on your
home uh we just I'm so grateful to God
we uh we we lived in like a
how much you own your home oh 6 uh 633
I'm sorry 633 we just what I would do if
I woke up in your shoes is I would take
three to six months of expenses given
that your husband likes to have a little
bit more let's say six months of what's
your household
income 250 okay all right so let's be
super generous okay set 100,000 aside
that's more than you need that's more
than 6 months okay and call that your
emergency fund it's a ridiculous
emergency fund let's set 100,000 side
everything above 100,000 is cray cray it
needs to be going on the
house it's just there you're not going
to have $100,000
emergencies can I ask another dumb
question no not dumb these aren't dumb
questions these are great questions do
you ever recommend if like you have
Investments do you ever recommend taking
those out and putting it towards the
house always or no always unless in re
unless they're in retirement
account okay you want to know why single
stock sell them you want to know
why why because when we studied the
largest study of millionaires ever done
in North America over 10,000 of them we
never found them saying we invested
instead of paying off our home and
that's how we became millionaires none
of them say
that okay almost all of them followed
the model of a steady reasonable amount
of investing like in their retirement
accounts then paid off the home and then
increased their investing when the home
was paid off and so the typical person
with say a million A5 doll net worth
their first one and a. half million of
net worth had A5 or $600,000 paid for
home and about a million dollar in their
401K but the number of them that said oh
we never pay off our house instead we
invested more and more and more and kept
the house debt was almost zero it was
less than
10% thank you that's helpful okay so the
data says that the best and the fastest
way to build wealth is get the house
paid off while steadily investing about
15% of your income above an emergency
fund of 3 to six months of expenses so
if you guys making 250 have squirel over
in an investment a half million dollars
I'm going to tell you get this house
paid off next 12 months and take that
money in there now not taking out 401K
money but I'm talking about you've just
got a you know you've got a brokerage
account of some kind over here with a
half million dollar sitting in it take
that and the 60 above the hundred and
throw it at the thing let's get this
house paid off because I got to tell you
if I ever get your husband to pay off
his house he will think he's a genius
and he'll never ever ever go back in
dead on that house well and I want to
make sure we point we we touch on this
this he's solving for safety and right
now safety for him is having a bunch of
cash yep and and non-retirement
investment that's right and he's hedging
his safety against all these other
things and he's got this big elephant
sitting in his living room and you We've
joked about this off air before no one
has ever called the show and said man
I'm really mad at y'all cuz I paid my
house off and six months later piss Dave
Ramsey told me to pay my house off I
wish I had my mortgage back love my
mortgage you could you say it all the
time you could always go take out a
mortgage 6 months from now if you don't
like it right if you don't like having a
paid for house but you think you're you
think you're solving for safety with all
these extracurricular activities try
sleeping in a house that you owe nobody
anything for that's a level of safety
that you didn't know your body could
feel until you go do it yeah I'm telling
you when when you have let's just talk
about safety okay when we have a fouchy
quarantine and the whole freaking Place
shuts down and your house is paid for
it feels a whole lot different inside
your physical body than having the same
amount of your mortgage in a mutual fund
because there's a part of your brain
that's been there for eternity that says
you're going to lose your house your
kids are going to be on the street yeah
100% of foreclosures happen on a house
with a mortgage that's right versus
being real frustrated right being
annoyed and frustrated that's different
than I can't breathe right yeah I mean I
had uh we had business stress we had
relational stress uh because of
disagreements but David Sharon Roy is
going to be okay over the coid you know
we found out who our friends were who
who were all worried about little CO's
jumping on people and all the stuff we
we dealt with all that stuff uh but we
didn't
deal during the fouchy quarantine with
the threat of foreclosure right not in
there and so when you're solving for
safety that was a good phrase I like
that phrase you know you you probably
need to really correctly Define safety
right and get the elephant out of your
dead gum living room right which is the
living room by the way yeah
ironically it it's and the way we said
it before we had John with two phds to
help us understand it was if your house
is paid for take your shoes off walk
through the backyard the grass feels
different you breathe different and um
you work you won't work at a toxic Place
anymore because you have to you're not
stuck anymore more folks and so the
solving for this is you know when I
first started teaching this stuff I
thought well if you got rid of a house
payment you invested a house payment you
can turn that money into a million
dollars pretty quick and that's the math
part the financial part but there's an
emotional part A Spiritual part A
relational part a medical health a
mental health part I you know someday it
it'll be done I I don't know that I'll
ever get around to doing it but a study
of the um medical condition and the life
quality of life and longevity of Life of
people who are debt-free versus those
that aren't they're they're quietly
starting to to leak out into the world
where people are doing mental health and
emotional health and debt and starting
to use the correlative data it's it's
it's pretty frightening yeah I've talked
to some doctoral students who are
interested in doing their dissertations
on student loans and people with debt
versus the mental health of those who
don't know anybody anything yeah and if
you think about this think about think
all of us um um have had the moment in
our career when we think oh man I got to
go have a hard conversation with my boss
I may not survive this one imagine your
wife or your husband can put your face
in their hands and look at you and say
hey we're going to be okay we got plenty
of money tell the trth we got plenty of
money we got no house payment go tell
the truth go be you and we don't have
any house payments man like that's a
different conversation